les entreprises d'aujourd'hui compte
entre 20 et 25 personnels
pour un chiffre d'affaires aux alentours
de 3 millions d'euros entreprise
spécialisée dans l'enveloppé extérieure
du bâtiment
tout ce qui est rapidement de façade
crépy isolation extérieure bardage la
fierté c'est dans des partis de zéro et
d'avoir mis en place une plateforme
sociale au service de tout le monde que
ce soit pour nous pour nos salariés pour
nos fournisseurs pour nos clients on
essaie vraiment de créer une harmonie
entre tous ces acteurs là pour que les
choses se passent bien
la réussite du der et elle est plutôt là
que sur le chiffre d'affaires
il est arrivé ce matin vous avez vous
les posez quand j'oublie l'après midi je
suis pas là toujours board est mon père
et d'un profil technicien niçois moi je
m'occupe des chantiers tu t'occupes du
reste c'est lui qui à l'initiative du
départ de notre pays d'origine dans la
france et puis c'est aussi lui qui était
à l'initiative de la création de
l'entreprise face à dijon il semblait
date de très longtemps alors dans une
photo de deux mois avant première
anniversaire l'oreille d'autres photos
devant la maison familiale de mon grand
père on voit sur la photo donc moi même
ma mère et ma tante et en est où là et
là on est entre amis qu un trust me
donner à l'endroit où nous on vient on a
passé une année dans un centre d'accueil
pour les réfugiés
avant de venir à besançon s'installer
ici récupère un appartement vide
dépendra du bsi 95 mais c'est pas même
chose c'est pas même chose on entre ici
avec un des valises avec deux les
enfants avec des balises ça a été facile
de s'intégrer débit hsi pour très facile
à prendre votre l'oncle sam c'est vrai
ça c'est pas c'est pas facile nous c'est
un peu différent parce qu'on a été
scolarisée donc on a pu apprendre la
langue à l'école mais
elle est là elle a appris sur le tas en
faisant les boules au café puis celui
qu'elle fait aujourd'hui qu'ils étaient
contents c'est parce que tout le monde
chez nous on travaille moi je travaille
c'est mon avis ça ne les emballe
moi je vais couper pour personnes âgées
à domicile serait beau couple et ça va
il a réussi de la familiale lui
appartient tout autant que mon père et
moi à vous on est aussi faire notre
maman s est elle s'est beaucoup sacrifié
pour nous donc aujourd'hui on est là on
semble chez elle c'est aussi pour lui
rendre hommage
voilà